Weaving and knitting to create fabric are
some of our oldest forms of technology
Now those ancient practices have become high
tech manufacturing,
and they are meeting up with cutting edge robotics to create artificial muscles
These textile actuators, or textuators, are
made from cellulose yarn.
Instead of dye, the yarn is coated with a
material called polypyrrole that moves in response to electricity
The textuators can be woven or knitted.
Woven forms can exert more force, but the
knitted ones can stretch and change shape
The fabric can be tweaked to give the right
balance of stretchiness and strength
This new fabric is designed to be manufactured
at industrial scales.
The technology could be integrated into potential
assistive devices like prosthetics or exoskeletons
One day, artificial muscles made of fabric
could be integrated into clothing to aid mobility